[Music]
in our weekend flash sale you'll get 12
weeks of the magazine
in print and online for just 12 pounds
and we'll also send you a bottle of
johnny walker black label
scotch whiskey to become a subscriber
today go to spectator dot co dot uk
slash flash sale the government has
ordered enough vaccine doses for the
entire
british population i'm told it's bought
more per capita than any other
country on earth based on the pfizer
madonna
and astrazeneca jams astrazeneca the one
with oxford university on that it seems
many people however are reluctant
about taking these vaccines that have
been created in record time
experts estimate that at least two
thirds of the population need to be
vaccinated
to reach herd immunity so how can the
reluctant be persuaded
to take the vaccine stuart ritchie is a
behavioral scientist at
king's college london he takes a stab at
this issue in this week's
edition of the spectator and he joins us
on spectator
tv now stuart richie welcome and thank
you for your time
first of all stu tell us how widespread
is this problem of vaccine skepticism
even vaccine denial
well just a few months ago the uh the
polls looked really good
uh 85 percent of people said that they
would be willing to take the vaccine
and actually interestingly it's got
worse since then you know as we've got
closer to
actually having vaccines the polls are
looking less and less
uh good um the pfizer poll for instance
there was a a yougov poll
uh showing about 67 of people said
they'd be fairly likely or or very
likely to take it
and that's lower than what we'd need for
herd immunity uh
there's different calculations that you
have to do of course and it's not
you know there's isn't just one number
for herd immunity but it depends on the
transmission rate of
the the virus and so on but um it's it's
it's
just about or just a bit lower than we'd
really want um
and also it's more complicated than that
the uh the the vaccine
uh spreads the virus spreads and
clusters and so we want to make sure
that
really much higher than the kind of
basic herd immunity
threshold is vaccinated so um
it's it's quite worrying to see these
polls and we really need to do something
about uh
convincing people to take this vaccine
the been
anti-vaccine movements in the past
there's always a kind of hardcore
of anti-vaxxers whenever vaccines uh
come up
they seem quite militant about it
they're prone to conspiracy theories of
time too
what i wonder though stewart is the is
this reluctance that you you're in
you've found is does this go broader
than the the what i might say the usual
suspects when it comes to anti-vaccines
yeah i think i think in psychology
research behavioral science research
whatever you want to call it
um they're starting to use the term uh
vaccine hesitancy rather than
anti-vaccine because
um there are people who are are
persuadable or possibly persuadable who
are not just that hardcore it does go
further than that hardcore
and because people are worried about it
there have been incidents in the past
where
uh uh you know vaccines have been have
been rushed and and so on and
there did seem especially in the us to
be sort of political involvement in this
trying to get the vaccine out before the
election obviously that
didn't happen but there had you know
there were sort of rumors of that and i
think
that all casts uh a really unfortunate
doubt on what has been a very very
uh open and safe process if you actually
look at the science
um you know the the the politicking has
been really unfortunate
so just to be clear on that beyond the
hard core of people who seem to be
against any kind of vaccine
the the there's a a bigger group
that is worried because this vaccine was
developed so quickly
that's that's clearly one aspect i think
um people
understandably want to see the safety
data i mean we don't actually have
full peer-reviewed papers for any of
these three vaccines that we've been
told about yet they've been
released in in press releases and the
initial data look good and i think the
incentives
are not for the vaccine companies the
pharma companies to be
you know misleading us on this i think
the incentives are you know
for them to be truthful and open about
this and they have been open
about some uh uh um you know
uh aspects of the of the of the
protocols of the the studies
astrazeneca there's a few more questions
but fire and moderna have been amazingly
transparent and open
um uh and so i you know i kind of look
at the the vaccine development as sort
of a bright spot in the science
uncovered which has been very patchy
uh overall but um i think people are
understandably saying i want to see the
paper i want to see
the the safety data i want it to be
assessed by the experts before i make a
decision that's that's fine and i think
the pharma companies should be
you know having absolute rocket boosters
under their um
paper writing they should all be writing
up their papers as quickly as possible
to try and convince people
i want to come on to how you think we
can nudge people
to the vaccine but before i do let me
ask a more fundamental question
is it really just out of the question in
a democracy
to make the vaccine mandatory
well it's not a question in some
democracy so some democracies nearby
uh for instance france uh has several
vaccines that are mandatory this is in
this is in kids
um uh um the
the us has uh management vaccines for
for going to school in many states
depends on the state
uh germany has some australia has these
no jab no pay laws where you don't get
your child benefit unless your kid has
been uh
vaccinated so there are some countries
that do
either compulsory vaccination or you
know stop you getting
your full government benefits and so on
if you if you don't get the vaccine
it's not something we have in this
country um and i actually think
it's uh it's probably not going to be
necessary in this case i think there's a
huge clamor
to to get to get vaccinated and i i
don't think we're going to necessarily
need it i think we can use incentives
you know that are
carrots rather than sticks well give us
some examples how would we
nudge people with a carrot and perhaps
with a stick
towards taking the vaccine well i mean
the most obvious one is simply to pay
people to take it
um i think the government should be very
thinking very carefully about
uh paying people especially younger
people who might think
that the vaccine oh it's not for us you
know the the this this virus really
affects older people they're at risk of
severe disease i'm not really i'm maybe
just going to get a male illness for a
while
i think um obviously that's that's the
wrong reasoning because uh the the virus
spreads
including from from younger people and
including from people who who don't have
symptoms and so um uh i think the
government should be thinking very
carefully about paying
younger people particularly to have a
vaccine maybe it's been suggested
200 pounds for for a shot particularly
important as well because you might
need two shots so you might need to
incentivize people to come back for the
second one
um and you know you do get a lot of
attrition in these kind of in these kind
of interventions
and so that's one thing there are other
things in
in the literature the psychology
literature is not particularly
impressive on this topic
about changing people's minds so making
people who are worried about the vaccine
or are
actually hardcore anti-vaccinators and
making them change their mind
we're not really very good at that we're
not very good at persuasion but there
are some things you know um making
people set specific appointments and
times that they can go and get the
vaccine
making sure that the the the clinics are
easily accessible and these kind of
nudges can
can work but actually changing people's
minds we're just not very good at that
could there also be a way in which
society penalizes the people who refuse
to take the vaccine for example
an airline could say if you haven't got
a vaccine you're not flying in our
airline
or even a restaurant owner might say if
you haven't got the vaccine
you're not dining in our restaurant
which is now rather crowded
yeah absolutely there's uh there's
private incentives as well so we saw the
ceo of qantas
uh saying that he's gonna i think he
hasn't officially said but he's thinking
about it
they're considering having some kind of
um so you have to show your passport for
an international flight you might also
have to show your immunity passport for
international flights
um and maybe even domestic flights as
well he was talking about in
australia so um i think that private
companies can can can do this as well
and
it's not just that they um that they
should do this because
it's a it's a useful thing to to do for
for building herd immunity
but it's also i mean it makes people
feel safer it's going to make people
want to use these companies
james is the current is the government
worried about vaccine skepticism does it
feel that there'll be
resistance uh among a decent sized chunk
of the population
i don't mean they're worried about
vaccine skepticism in the first
instance i think their i think their
view is that you know
initially the take-up will be quite high
i think the question will the worry will
come if you haven't hit
uh we know from these leaked nhs
documents they want to hit 75
by april and i think if you're
struggling to get to that number
then i think you get into more difficult
rounds of as you said how do you nudge
people to take the vaccine
uh i think the problem is lots of the
nudges that people talk about like
paying people to take the vaccine and
the like
i think might will actually have the
perverse effect of increasing people's
skepticism of the vaccine i see what you
mean because they feel they'll be kind
of bribed
uh to to do it i can what do you say to
that last year that's an interesting
point
yeah i think these backfire effects are
definitely the case i think particularly
if it was compulsory people would think
well wait a minute why aren't we giving
why aren't we being given a choice here
are they hiding something about the
safety of this
uh vaccine and and particularly you know
um
being paid which is why i think the
being paid thing could be directed at
specific
uh portions of the population rather
than just rather than just everyone
um but yeah i think look i think we're
in a really lucky position here
the vaccine is really safe it's uh the
modern and the pfizer ones seem to be
amazingly effective you know 90 percent
95 percent uh and so actually i think
the aspects
the the properties of the vaccine itself
are reasons why we won't have to
you know bend over backwards to get
people to take it people are going to be
really
desperate to take this vaccine and and
um you know it's not just like
a routine health appointment in this
case it's your whole world opening up
again and
and so i think there are reasons to be
optimistic about this although we need
to
think carefully and we need to be
flexible too we need to
you know keep a real eye on those
numbers and and
put in some new policies in place if you
know we're not getting up to that level
of herd immunity
final issue and uh i'll come to katy
then
finish off with you stuart uh here uh
katy you've written about the question
surrounding the the order the priority
of who should get the vaccinations
uh first what what's the government
thinking on on this yet is there a clear
order of priority uh developing as
government policy
yes so the government priority is is
pretty clear which is the vulnerable
and the aged first as well as health
workers nhs workers
and they've printed you know they
publish documents about this
and i think that if you there's some
questions
about the oxford vaccine though there
has been good news on the surface
at least but ultimately if we're faced
with a scenario where the vaccines first
approved we have limited
supplies on and also just in terms of
the choice of the highest you know
efficacy
that will go to you know the 55 and
overs first as
nhs workers too however uh
if we are in a situation where we have
limited supplies of vaccines
expect to see tory mps questioning the
order because
there's already been some uh you know uh
chewing and throwing
from tory mps saying if you can't
vaccinate you know 75
of the country then actually there is an
argument that perhaps you vaccinate uh
working age people first people who need
to get out there and do
things rather than vaccinate those who
aren't really going to be going out
there and taking part in society in such
a way
and i think that debate rests on
ultimately you know
how how many doses there are to go
around if ox is approved
it it will probably diminish and i think
one other thing just when we're talking
about how you get people to take um
vaccines recently there was a tory mp he
wrote on the tory mp whatsapp thread
that perhaps mp
should be at the you know near the front
of the queue and they were
quite quickly shot down people suggested
this to be a bad look
um but there was interesting polling i
think in the daily mail which was
saying that actually quite a lot of the
public believe that
um if their mp took it first it would
give them
confidence and so i think that is one to
watch
and perhaps we're going to get
vaccinations in the chamber
oh very well get them live on television
why not
yeah it could replace strictly when it
comes to an end
stuart final question with you uh uh
what do you think the priority
should be this idea working age people
should get it first i mean i always
thought that
the natural thing to do would be people
at the front line nhs and so on
then those most vulnerable the older and
then those with
uh particularly with underlying
comorbidities and then those
of any age with these comorbidities and
then everybody else is that
is that wrong that that seems very
sensible to me although there will be
um modeling studies that will show uh
i'm pretty sure that there there are
epidemiologists working right now on uh
studies that will
you know um uh simulate different
strategies that we could take
and uh and it really all depends on the
uh
uh the effectiveness of the vaccines too
so if this uh astrazeneca vaccine is 70
effective that's going to mean a
different model from if it's 90
effective and we really don't know the
answer to that yet so a lot of this is
going to hinge on
um particularly because the government
has bought you know
its largest proportion of vaccines that
it's bought
are the astrazeneca ones that's really
going to depend on on how effective
those vaccines are
so we really need to see from oxford as
soon as possible that paper giving all
the details of all the
uh the protocol how it was changed uh um
uh if if indeed it was changed uh and
and
no not only that but also the safety
information and then we can start
modeling
who we should be giving the vaccines to
[Music]
first
[Music]
you